قررت فرنسا سحب سفيرها وبالتالي سيعود مع
العديد من الدبلوماسيين الى فرنسا في
الساعات القادمه
[موسيقى]
ويبدو حسب وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه انه تم
في ظل تقييم شامل لوضع البعثتين
الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه الفرنسيه الموجوده
في النيجر من بينها يعني النفاذ
الغذاء وكذلك المياه الصالحه لشرب وان
الوضع لم يعد ملائما لاستمرار وجود السفير
الفرنسي هناك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وسننهي تعاوننا العسكري مع سلطات الامر
الواقع في النيجر لانها لم تعد ترغب في
مكافحه الارهاب
حكام وانيميا الجدد يراهنون على انهم
عسكريون على انهم سيحاولون ان يبسط الامن
حاولوا ان يقنعوا الشعب وانا كنت عدت منها
قريبا حاولوا ان يضخوا خطابا طيله
الاسابيع الماضيه انهم عسكر وانهم قادرون
على بطل الامن وان يعني المح الى ان
الرئيس السابق هو رئيس المدني ربما لا
يملك القوه الكافيه للسيطره